[Music]
hello everyone um welcome to our webinar
uh which is titled as automated sample
preparation for
reproducible clinical proteomics um a
good morning good afternoon wherever you
are dialing in from
and
we are actually going to have some very
exciting uh discussions today as three
excellent talks that we have lined up
for you in this hour
uh today's educational web seminar is
presented
by lab roots and
brought to you by covaris
and of course you can get a lot more
information about how adaptive focused
acoustics can be done
for proteomics clinical proteomics
protein analysis from our website
www.covaris.com so without further ado
i would like to introduce the first
speaker or that we have today uh my
friend and colleague dr nicola ray
and he has an extensive experience and
background in the world of proteomics
and has been a part of our organization
um for several years
so he's going to kick start today's uh
webinar by introducing adaptive focused
acoustics technology to you all and then
also introduce the other speakers at the
end of his presentation so nicola
great to have you on board
thank you deb for the nice introduction
hi everyone
so um today my short talk will be about
introducing
the basics of adaptive focused acoustics
but uh as a first slide i'd like to
introduce why we decided to jump into uh
the field of sample preparation for
programming because we engage with a lot
of
customers and users of mass spectrometry
and as they told us that there are a lot
of um
problems issues in in bottlenecks that
they face and the first problems that
they have
is reproducibility and repeatability and
what is causing irreproducibility is of
course the variations you see during the
process
as a second issue they wanted to have
the ability to automate further and to
standardize and normalize their
preparations which would also help them
reduce the turnaround time
then miniaturization is very important
because there is a clear trend in the
market to
reduce the inputs and to avoid sample
loss because of
you know the material being very
precious and last but not least people
have more and more samples to process
they want to increase the throughput but
also have workflows that are compatible
with liquid handlers
so because your samples deserve the best
treatment i would like to introduce now
our solutions so what covers this is
really pre-analytical sample prep
instrumentation and we have different
tools to support that and what will be
discussed today is mainly our
developments in um
adaptive focused acoustics where we
provide focused and tunable energy
supply which allows thermal control it's
absolutely non-contact and it's
available in a lot of formats as you
will see in the next presentation
and um as i said replacement
reproducibility is really the key part
that we bring here and it's based on our
unique technology which allows to
deliver energy with a lot of control to
the sample and one of the results of
that is that we don't create heat which
can be a problem with non-focused energy
like probe syndication or what about
syndication so because we are focused we
can also ensure an identical treatment
between whales bitumens
and because it's isothermal we preserve
the proteins as compared to this other
syndication technology
and also what we bring to these sample
prep approaches is the throughput
parallel processing in 96 and straight
forward format which to our knowledge is
really unique today
so what you will hear
about today is the different workflows
that we can support you will hear about
ffpe and fresh frozen tissues in cells
but we also have ways to
promote native extraction like in
immunopeptidomics workflows as described
recently by diagnosis or for low input
processing of laser capture micro
dissected samples
as we do in collaboration with leica
instrumentation
beyond this presentation you can find a
lot of information on our website
covaris.com proteomics you will find our
latest application notes our latest
guides to use the technology and that
will ensure that your samples get the
best treatment
i'm now very
happy to introduce the next speakers so
right after me
professor john kaisfield will uh present
his work uh where he uses
afa
so javon received his phd
in
biochemistry and molecular biology from
university of amsterdam and after being
assistant professor at the university of
literature he moved to heidelberg in
2008. there he first worked at the embl
where he among other responsibility led
the proteomics core facility in 2016 he
joined the german cancer research center
or the kfc as both a professor at
heidelberg university and as head of the
proteomics of stem cell and cancer
division
our second speaker will be dr ignacy
farnay who owns a phd
from university autonomous university of
barcelona he has also more than 70 peer
review publication and he is currently a
member of axel hemos groups at the
biomedical center of ludwig maximilian
university in munich where he is the
technical head of the proteomics
facility
and now i'm happy to leave the floor to
great thank you nicola for the
introduction and for having me on this
webinar and to have a chance to
um present some of our work here and uh
you pitched it really really nicely
because in your first slides you exactly
pointed out the uh the elements that are
you know important for us to improve our
proteomics workflow
um to automate is make it more sensitive
and reproducible so that's exactly what
i'll be talking about
captured in my title here
and
so what we have established is
summarized in in this slide here
where we have been working during the
last years
to improve our sample preparation
workflow and to automate this wherever
possible
not only for
tissue lysis
using the
the gophers a phase indicator
but also for the protein cleaner cleanup
step where we have developed this auto
sp3
protocol that is shown in the middle of
the slide here and all this is connected
to
lcms for
proteomic investigation of these samples
i should also say
and that will hopefully be clear become
clear
during this presentation so we have
various different types of samples that
we like to process
indicators on the left so what i'll do
in this presentation is first show how
we establish this workflow um and then
show examples of uh the different sample
types and and clinical and research
questions that we have
before getting to the the afa i'll first
introduce our sp3 workflow
um which is actually where things got
started for us where we have um
implemented this for a
protein cleanup so it's universal method
for protein cleanup for you know any
kind of assembled preparation
it's based on magnetic beads shown on
this slide here
where binding of proteins can be
promoted by
addition of organic solvent
which can then be
so the capture proteins can be captured
on a magnet
um allowing washing and removing removal
of um
[Music]
contaminants
this is then followed by a digestion of
proteins which can be directly analyzed
by mass spectrometry without any further
cleanup in by by far most cases
so this is
how it looks so it's really a
methodology where proteins are
aggregated on these beads
which happens specifically in organic
inorganic solvent and when protein is
present is as you see in the in the four
middle box
uh boxes here um on this microscopic
images so you see proteins or beets
aggregating where proteins are present
and they are this aggregating when they
are moved to aq solution again
and in the image on the right side you
even see this with the naked eye so you
it's a very nice way to actually have an
indication
uh that you have protected your sample
because if you don't then you don't see
this
this clumping of
beads together on the magnet
it's a very nice methodology and
because it's it's unbiased and because
it's um applicable to a lot of
experimental conditions where it
tolerates a lot of
chemicals
so it's important to emphasize it's a
non-selective methodology
to capture
all protests in a sample as indicated on
the left side
as just
the page image where you see
the proteins across the molecular weight
range are all captured
and then in this little table you see um
a list of deterge a list of components
detergents and kaotropes and salts and a
lot of other things that we've tested
and where binding is
is possible even at high concentration
of these these reagents so this gives a
lot of
flexibility in the the sample
preparation up front of the sp3
preparation
and there you see in the third image
this
a chromatogram of a yeast digest that
was purified with sp3 out of a one or
ten percent uh sds solution
and you get you know perfect
chromatography and no residual sds
present so it's very efficient
uh efficient cleanup and then the the
other advantage is that it has high
sensitivity which will become apparent
in the next slides that we can
analyze low sample inputs
we've implemented this on a robotic
system as displayed here
i won't go into details here the
procedure at the bottom half of the
slide is exactly as i showed
just a second ago and this has now been
implemented on a robotic system we use a
bravo system
um from ageland but
i know that various other other labs
have implemented this on other types of
robotic systems so this should work well
in many on many different platforms
so this allows us now to do this on in a
96 well plate format um in a in a
hands-free manner
now up front of of the sp3 workflow we
have
now i think two years ago we have
implemented
the
sonication device for
sample lysis and protein extraction
which has been very useful for
various applications as i will show
it's also a nice combination without sp3
workflow because the plate sort of 96
valve plate that you can use for
protein extraction
um on this indicator can be directly
placed on the deck of the
robotic platform
for subsequent protein cleanup
so one of the things that we tested
is
you know how sensitive the system is and
if we can work with with
low cell input and it's indicated here
on this slide where we have analyzed the
dilution series um
of cells serial dilution going from five
thousand or ten thousand cells down to
uh ten cells or even one cell of course
you cannot guarantee this is a single
cell because it's a dilution but it's
you know just to indicate that we can
get to very low um cell numbers and
still identify a few hundred proteins
even if you have 10 or 50 cells
and this is analyzed on the broker temps
of mass spectrometer and on the higher
end so with thousands or five thousand
cells you get really protein
identifications ranging into the into
the thousands so it's really very
efficient um
methodology
so what i'll show in the next slides is
uh some more clinically oriented um
applications where you know aim really
has been to use this platform as i
described it for the different sample
types that we that we receive from
collaborators
so this includes fresh frozen tissue
ffpe
but also sorted cells
and plasma
and i have examples for
most of this here
so one thing that we tested is how
efficiently we can
extract proteins from various tissue
types
so these are mouse tissues from heart
liver kidney and healer cells as a kind
of control
where we have
um
tissue chunks of of different sizes
as you'll see in the middle graph so
between one and what is it six seven
milligram
um where we're able to extract around
100 microgram of protein per milligram
of wet tissue which is you know plenty
of material to work with so even if you
have a one
milligram of material this should be a
very good starting point
for this
workflow and the absolute amount of
protein that you get that you can
extract from the tissue is actually more
inherent to the to the type of tissue so
you see here so in the red
symbols
that from heart we are able to extract
a little less protein because it's
likely because it is this rather sturdy
tissue type compared to
lung for instance
um now this is a really a clinic
application um of um
sorted cells so by fact sorting and um
it's a bit full slide and not go into
details but just to indicate that this
is
a study from a large sam uh patient
cohort um investigating a new treatment
um experimental treatment of
myeloma
and the question was really how a
particular antibody treatments so that's
in the title here isotoxin map um how
this contributes to the welfare of
patients
um
and that's indicated on the you know the
top part of the
of the figure here um how the study
design was done and where actually
several hundreds of patients are
enrolled
so we see these
we will see these
samples coming our way in the near
future so it's important to have a
workflow in place where we can do this
in a reproducible manner
and
so we'll do this from sorted cells as
shown at the bottom
we analyze typically less than 100 000
which is
plenty of material
and identifying some 5000 produce or so
in single-shot mass spec analysis
this is an example of fresh tissue
analysis
from
epinema which is a tumor in the central
nervous system
and in the left scheme you see with
these color codes the the different
subgroups that have been identified in
this disease
by dna methylation profiling so very
different techniques than than
proteomics
and our question was
if we could recapitulate the subgrouping
by by proteomics
so we were able to receive
close to 100 of these samples
with the numbers as indicated
and these were all processed
in the 96 well plate
by the afa sp3 workflow
identifying over 8 000 proteins
and from the disney plot in the middle
you can see
that samples from the same subgroup
cluster together indicating that indeed
we are able to recapitulate the
subgrouping and this can also be refined
uh or actually
we looked into into more detail
in the heat map on the right
where we can assign
specific proteins that are specifically
expressed in the
in the different subgroups which is now
a topic of course of further
investigation to
to see if we can gain any mechanistic
insight of why these proteins are
different differently expressed in these
different
locations
now particularly a challenging sample
type is
ffpe so formalin-fixed paraffin embedded
samples
because they are cross-linked and
because of the paraffin that is that is
present in these samples
and
we were very happy to
[Music]
to note actually that
the afa based workflow can be very very
efficiently used to remove paraffin
the workflow is very similar to what i
explained in the beginning what we need
to do in addition is to
add a higher percentage of sds and to
incubate is at 95 degrees centigrade
and do this in you know two cycles so
heat up and then sonicate twice
and what happens then is what you can
see in the photographs on the top right
so you start with a little chunk of of
tissue
in in
the
lysis buffer
and after sonication and heating you see
this milky sample which looks you know
scary if you want to
see this as a sample that you need to
inject into your mass spectrometer but
actually after after cleanup
by sp3 this clears up as as transparent
as it started in the beginning and
you're able to
after that protein digestion able to
inject this directly for mass back
analysis without any further
peptide cleanup
there's an additional you know step of
you you need to do a bit more harsh um
clean up with the solvents indicated in
the bottom right
but this works uh quite nicely and we're
doing this now for a large number of
numbers of samples
so one example is here where we looked
into
the adenocarcinoma
which
can be observed phenotypically
or by pathologists in different growth
patterns as shown on the left
which has been associated with
different you know severity of the
disease
so we wanted to investigate if this
these growth patterns were associated
with any particular protein expression
profiles
so
we
through our collaborators we were able
to obtain tissue sections from
from a number of patients
and
these different growth patterns could be
excised
from these tissues in
replicates in sections that were
directly sections from the same tissue
as indicated in the middle
um
producing some you know 50 samples from
eight patients that we then
analyzed in a random manner
through the
workflow i explained
which then looked as follows so
on the left you see a disney plot of
these 50 samples and i don't know if you
can see it but if you look carefully you
see these pairs of dots that appear
together
with the same color so these are
replicas replicate samples that ended up
almost on top of each other in the
disney analysis
indicating how reproducible this is and
despite the fact that all of these were
analyzed in a randomized manner
um and again not going through details
but now we are you know looking um into
uh differences in protein expression um
exemplified by the volcano plot on the
right
and trying to understand
or explain the difference in expression
of particular proteins and associate
this with these growth patterns
another application of
ffpe is
actually a
an approach where we didn't
end up analyzing tissue slices but
rather biopsy punches as shown on the
right side
um so this is an example of
sarcoma
and where a pathologist can
traditionally look at these images as in
the in the middle of the slide and then
indicate
um
based on
on staining and microscopy what areas
are of interest and these are punched
out from a tissue block as shown on the
right
and these were collected in
the afa plates for proteome analysis
and just to indicate you know the time
it takes for doing this type of analysis
so for 96 samples
it takes about four hours to
do the tissue extraction
tissue lysis departurization extraction
of proteins
then we get about 20 micrograms of salt
per punch
the subsequent sp3 cleanup takes two
hours then overnight digestion and then
actually the the build of the time goes
into mass spec analysis where we in this
example take two hours per sample taking
eight days for
96 samples
what we noted is
that you know these tissue punches are
not not homogeneous
um and so we observe quite some
variability um
and the reason is that these punches go
quite deeper at least quite a bit deeper
than the pathologist can see through the
microscope from the top
so what we actually
do now is that we and because we take we
obtain quite some protein from a single
punch
we slice this
into
[Music]
five or six
slices as shown in the right
panel
and
we take that usually the top part of
such a punch only for proteome analysis
because this corresponds to what the
pathology sees through the microscope
as a last example and this is you know
as first as close to
to you know clinic clinics as it gets
so this is a trial called catch
uh or registry trial for advanced stage
metastatic breast cancer so these are
patients that have
brief actually no no treatment options
so they have gone through
a long road of treatments and in the end
um none of them worked and so this is
a study where they look at these
patients case by case where they collect
you know all the all the information
that they can put their hands on so the
clinical information but they also do
ion sequencing
dna sequencing methylon profiling etc
and then put all these data together and
then sit around the table literally
with
clinical experts from different
directions
and decide for individuals how they may
be treated
um so what i did not have
until recently was a proteome analysis
um
and actually so the protein samples
they had as leftovers in their freezers
because what they do is um that they
isolate rna dna from um
from a tissue piece and then are left
with protein in a five percent sds
solution
um which they couldn't do much with um
until we discussed it and noting that
with our sp3 approach we could come in
quite smoothly um because it's a perfect
starting point for for further cleanup
so that's what we're doing now um yeah
seeing what we what you can contribute
here so we are now in the process of
generating these proteome uh data sets
and feed this into this you know
decision in this you know circle that
you see on the left
um and then evaluate if this is you know
helpful for decision making by the
clinicians
so that's um
ends my presentation actually so what i
would like to show so just as a summary
so for us a phase allocation with outer
sp3 is a is a very good match
for streamlined proteome analysis
where you
start with tissues
producing peptides that are ready to go
for mass spec analysis for any type of
sample
so it has very minimal
sorry minimal manual intervention so you
only need to transfer the plate from the
sonicator to the
pipetting robot into the outer sampler
so i can actually do a lot of samples
per day
if you want you can generate 300 samples
in the working day next question of
course is when are you going to analyze
these so my aspect time is limiting as i
mentioned
what's very attractive of course is that
it's highly standardized producing low
cvs i didn't show it here but you can
look up the paper there we have on the
right side we have all the details
and what is nice is that it accepts a
very low sample input
so with this
i'd like to thank um
the people who were involved here sir
thorsten miller and
georg cleaver my group did most of the
work here and so the rest of my group
are clinical collaborators in the middle
and last but not least
nicola for
help and advice and
staying tuned all the time it was highly
appreciated
thanks for your attention and if you
have any questions i guess there will be
a chance to ask in the q a later
okay
hello everybody as nicola presented
already
i'm ignacio for me i'm working
at the proteomics core facility from the
biomedical center
um and
today i'm going to talk you about the
benefits that we are seeing in our
facility
of the adaptive focused acoustics
technology
so we are located in the south of munich
and
a campus called martin street where many
institutes not only from the element but
also for max plan
and and from helmholtz institute
are located and
we are basically providing the
programming technologies state of the
art proteomics technologies to to all
these labs around max plan not obviously
they have their own facilities but
basically the lmu handholds and
university hospital
so
we are here okay in this building here
that is highlighted and and
we are
offering these proteomics facilities
technologies to the institutes around
and basically for those that are not
familiar for with a
classic workflow for bottom up
proteomics these are divided in three
different parts the sample preparation
the lcms itself and the data analysis
from the sample preparation
uh what you have to do is to extract the
proteins from cells and tissues that to
to be able to digest them and and then
with the peptides that you have
that you have generated up to digestion
you are going to separate them with an
lc that is coupled to an ms that can be
operated in several modes
and uh and then once you have the data
recorded
where you have
the information about the masses of the
peptides and the
fragments that you can generate what
you're going to do is
identify those peptides quantify those
patterns in several
approaches depending what you've planned
before experimentally
and uh finally you're going to generate
a list of proteins present in each of
the samples that you have analyzed
and
with the identification and the
quantification
so and it's basically in the first vlog
of this general approach where
we took advantage of
covaris instruments
initially we started with an s220 this
is a
small device that is able to allocate
one sample per
per time and and this was available at
our institute and it was has been used
for cheap analysis mainly and
we get interested into into covaris at
that point where we were
starting with ffpe samples with low
amounts of material
and
because we were happy with this then we
decided to purchase a year ago
around a year ago
the
e220 which gives you much more
throughput so you can allocate up to 96
samples
uh
although it's focusing between the the
sonication once one sample at a time
and but it allows you quite a
flexibility in terms of
tubes and amounts and volumes that you
can measure that you can
sonicate so basically we can go up to
from 50 microliters volume to one
milliliter and i'm going to show an
example where we go very low and where
we use almost 1 milliliter and the
applications as i mentioned already so
we've been using the previous one the s
220 for cheap and next generation
sequencing and we then move to
proteomics
um
so and the advantages of
other principles uh nikola already
mentioned that and what we
were happy uh
especially for proteomics was that the
the samples were not hit a lot because
the
yeah sonication it's taking place in a
very defined focal point you can control
intensity cycle cycles and time and
everything
everything takes place in a water cooled
path which allows you to lift the
samples
especially if you have 96 samples you
can program
those samples and leave that for the
next four or five hours whatever it
takes to
sonicate all these all these samples
so
after this general introduction on
proteomics and on the cobarius
instrument itself what i'm going to talk
about i'm going to present you three
different projects in which we took
advantage of the faa
and i'm going to start with a
collaboration with the group of maria
elena torres
and the hellholtz institute for
epigenetics and
stem cells and in there the idea
was to study
which were the proteins that were
defined in a successful pre-implantation
process and
at which point the homogeneity on
on the protein content was disrupted
during this plantation process so to
start
defining which is the cellular content
the protein content of these cells
what we decided to do was to analyze
the embryo mouse embryos are different
cell stages
from zygote to blastocyst at individual
cells so
what we did was to collect form each of
the six stages between 28 and 30
individual
embryos and place them into covaris
tubes
and then these covalence tubes then
where
so the samples in this cobaster were
directly processed so we were
applying uh ultrasonication there was a
heating there was a digestion a labeling
with tmt
and finally
those
digested proteins so the peptides coming
from these digested proteins that were
already labeled
we could directly inject into the lc
system thanks to
[Music]
eyes that generously
generously given by karl meklar from the
amp in
bean
basically you can put the
tubes after after
after all the process
in the lca auto sampler and then program
the injection from all these individual
samples directly into a drop column and
this tab column it's going to merge all
the different labels from those
different samples so for those
who has an idea about the tmt labeling
so basically
we end up
with 24 different injections each
injection was having um eight different
samples together with a carrier and a
and a blank and then we also internal
standard and with this um
this is how it
looked in theory and does it this is how
it looked uh
at the end we were having all the
samples and the advantage of of doing
everything into
these virus tubes was basically the fact
that we didn't have to
remove any sample from the tube so there
was no not sample loss
and
we were having all steps on in this one
port and where only the peptides were
injected directly into the lcd and in
this way we can
we could observe already
around 6 700 proteins
800 proteins sorry that
that are then clustered in six different
clusters in this heat map
and that we are
that we are now integrating with the
other omics
analysis that the group of marijuana
have been performing with this kind of
samples that we could already observe is
that we the individual samples that we
analyze at a cluster
in a pca when we observe the different
developmental stages
so uh the second application in which we
took advantage of covaris
was
one study that we did in collaboration
with the group of doctor toviah
schweitzer
hospital
from the university
in which they were aiming to identify
the
proteins that
could have a pathological role in the
onset of
this disease here is a methylic
esophagitis
which is a disease
that
it's not
completely known what
the cause is
but uh but it's thought to have an
allergic or um
good intake origin
and
what happens here is that due to this uh
allergy to either
food or other hierarchies
the esophagus got swollen and this
impulse um
the the use of of the sofa was for food
intake and it's as you can imagine it's
very
inconvenient and
so
what
we decided to do here to answer these
two questions that you see now on the
on the screen
was to um
collect
samples from
54 different patients
that
[Music]
that were
[Music]
basically taken at the beginning when
the first visit was uh was done at the
hospital and then was
with us all the biopsies were taken from
the same patient at different time
points of the treatment so that we can
follow which is the evolution of the
disease there were also two con 10
controls that
were
related to an allergic inflammatory
process so this card that you're seeing
in yellow
and 10 other
patients from functional disorders that
are not inflammatory and
but and they are
histologically not affected
so in total we end up with 151
samples and these since 51 samples
were
were prepared as described here so
basically the biopsy was taken then it
was
fixed an embedded in
in paraffin so that we get the ffbe for
archive and once all the
all the patients were
present for the for the study
then one scroll of around 10 micrometers
was taken d paraffinized
and then
the only the epithelium region of
of this tissue section
was taken was micro dissected at the at
the technical university of munich in
the
in the pathology department
and only this epithelium is what we
treated
with uh with kovaris in light buffer
using the h-drive microtubes in order to
generate the proteome that we could
analyze later on so in here we're not we
were not doing individual tubes but here
we were using the stripes again
similar conditions as as we used before
with for the single cells
and
for this we were happy that we could
recapitulate the
clinical story of
of several patients here i'm just
showing one example
so basically on the left what you see
are different parameters that are
measured for one patient uh at the first
visit this will be baseline and the
other
four visits and you see that
for the green lines when you see the
oceano fields present in the
in
the present in the astrological tissues
you see that there's a decrease uh from
visit one two and three where there's
almost nothing this is between three and
four everything looks okay and at visit
four there's again uh
an onset of the
of the disease and this is also what we
see on the
on the other panel on the
on the right side
in which all the different measurements
for the 150 patients are plotted and
only those belonging to the same patient
are highlighted you will see that
um point one two and five which are uh
related to baseline visit two and five
uh in which we
have high levels of your snowfield so
indicating that there's an inflammation
and there's an uh problem in the
software was uh grouped together uh
while those that are four and five and
visit four and
three where we don't have using office
they clustered together
and so not only this we were also able
to identify
up to 70 biomarkers that we are now
testing and
that we are now testing with other means
to confirm the
the
implication in the different mechan
mechanisms that are implicated in
the theology
of of this disease
and
my last application this is a
collaboration with the group of
stephanie pete
which is
a which is a group leader in the
institute for stroke and dementia at the
university hospital of the
of the element
and the the question that they came
to us was if we were able
to identify the different protein levels
uh the different proteins present
at the thrombi and if we could
if we could
we could identify
the origin of those thrombi depending on
the different protein composition of of
these thrombis
and for this
what what they do they can
they can get out of the
of the arterial when
the the trombi the strombe has complete
different
size
and consistency and length depending on
the patient
and the
initial idea was to
uh freeze with liquid nitrogen the
strombe then pulverize them and then
from this
homogenous solution to the regular
sample preparation as i was explaining
before measure that uh with the cms and
then analyze
analyze that results using several of
the
of the softwares from
from the
available max quality sales and other
error scripts and and here is where we
took advantage
uh from the
the one milliliter tube that i was
mentioning before basically because uh
as i said
this strongly are completely
heterogeneous and they are not only
heterogeneous from patient to patient
but also within the same thrombi so it
didn't make too much sense to
slice past parts of the
of the thrombi and just analyze the end
the middle or the bottom but rather to
get a homogeneous solution
and for this
we took advantage of this cryoprep box
in which we could
add
the thrombi after leophil is
lyophilizing them
then once we have in there and frozen
then we can smash it pulverize it uh and
this power can be easily
transferred
into the one and then to the one mil
tubes
and this
and this one mil tube can be used
directly to
to uh
homogenize the sample in the in the
components
or you can use this as uh
as a recipient to to keep it for future
analysis in our class what we did was to
normalize because we knew the amount of
dry
powder that we were having in each of
the tubes we were normalizing with
the light buffer to have similar
uh concentrations of of proteins in
in each of the tubes after
after doing the homogenization and and
this is how it looks like uh here i have
to say well that's that's why there's a
star here that this is not exactly um
it's not exactly a trombone sample
that's why it looks so white because
actually they look very red so but the
the
the idea is this so that you add
the light buffer in here and then you
can
you can actually homogenize how much
you're nice enough this
this solution that you can test
afterwards for protein content with a
pca and then continue with a regular
analysis
and with this i want to do a
mix summary and acknowledgement
slide
uh i want to thank the group of maria
elena torres padilla together with
kenichiro and hiromi from the helmholtz
institute of genetics and stem cells
close rise to our place then um
mate
dickens stephan deed and
it is a wolfer from the institute for
stroke and dementia research
for the for the last project that i was
showing and for the second project i was
showing the group from the
uh haunted shack in the hospital from
the limbo clinic
the group of tobiah schweitz
and lose a friend
and last inside our institute we are so
lucky to have a bioinformatics core
facility which which we cooperate a lot
because we're just simply
in the same pipeline we generate uh as
the data
in the best quality as possible so that
our colleague tobias trump from the
bioinformatics facility can
plot the data
as nice as i showed you before
and
to finish as a big thank to uh
the group where uh belonging from the
professor axel improv
uh and especially to teresa watt who was
uh who was leading
the promise project and and uh
and all of you for your attention so i
guess now we will have time for a
general q and a session
so deb are you thinking are you taking
control
yes yes yeah thanks so much uh
ignaci uh carolyn and nico um wonderful
presentation and uh
great insight
so um as expected
with the quality of uh
presentation and data that was shared
there are a lot of other lot of
questions that were submitted and also
to
the audience that's tuned in right now
um please feel free to submit your
questions
using the q a
box
and
let us get started we have a few minutes
to spare
we of course
you know that gives us some wonderful
opportunity to have a good discussion
amongst
the speakers over here
so uh the first question that actually
um i would like to bring up is um is for
um geruin um which is
basically uh it's asking that uh for the
qms with uh
uh tandem tags
uh
we the the the person who asked the
question that they need to do protein
determination
can you do the protein determination
directly after sp3 cleanup before
digestions i guess asking for intact
um yeah you can do it after clean up but
usually we do it actually before
uh
the protein levels are not at the
peptide level so the usually the way we
do it is that we digest the proteins
right off the beads
so it's actually quite hard to elude
proteins off the beads
uh so if you do a protein two
termination you should do it before um
there are also kits for for duties at
the peptide level um that you can also
do yeah
excellent yes um and the second question
actually um is for
um ignacy
um so
um
ignacy do you feel uh
based on the multiple projects that you
know uh that you highlighted do you feel
this technology of adaptive focused
acoustics can be as impactful when
working with plasma
we're there
i mean we don't have experience on this
um so
so normally plasma proteins
are already available in solutions so
i guess you can take advantage on the
digestion so i know there's some
some applications in which you can take
in which you can speed the trypsin
digestion by having
uh
if yeah so the the sonication applied in
a combined instrument for extraction i
guess
it's not completely necessary but i i
don't have too many experience i i
foresee it for the for the digestion i
guess yeah
yes and just to add to that i think you
know one of the things that we see
plasma is that you know homogenization
is not that much of a challenge but you
know i think one of the things that we
see uh is that the pull down binding
efficiency digestion efficiency all
those things are also very critical
where and
you can benefit a lot by having a
non-invasive temperature controlled uh
sonication process going on in the
background which
actually brings me back to uh
my third question
um and that's for nico
so essentially nico it's a very broad
ended question is how does afa work and
what are its main advantages so you
probably have to redo a long
presentation now
absolutely so uh first thing if you want
to hear more about how afa works please
uh send us a request for a web meeting
and we'll be happy to go in more details
but rapidly we have an essential piece
in the instrument named the transducer
and that piece of equipment is able to
generate at high frequencies
energy into really the center of the
tube really in the middle of the sample
because then it is a very small
wavelength
and we can work with different
parameters to decide if we go for high
energy low energy and how it is
delivered
excellent
i think you know that uh that sums up in
a in a very nice way uh in in one minute
uh elevator presentation um
uh next question um is actually for
gerund um have you compared afa with
other sonication techniques
to see if they affect the results in
the same way or in some other way
yeah we've tried we've
well that's what it is so we have used
other devices we have not compared them
side by side
um
so we started with in our probe
communication but then wanting to go to
lower input and smaller volumes that
obviously doesn't work
uh we have used a digital node device um
there you can process it up to eight
samples i believe
um but the advantage and
you know i i know this is a
you know comparison stock
not to advertise too much but still to
mention the advantage i mean going
through higher sample numbers um is is
what attracted to us what what was
attractive for us
um excellent thanks so much
we will take that advertisement
[Laughter]
so uh
the
next question is actually for nico uh
again um what is the maximum energy that
you can deliver and can you lies
harder cells and high volume uh samples
one milliliter
um i think the question is that if you
can do one milliliter in 96 well format
well that's probably not going to happen
um because it won't accommodate but uh
the other parts maximum energy and
capability lies harder cells
so
i think that it's not very
appropriate to speak really about energy
but more about what you want to achieve
with that energy and so i would rather
say that you can go from full disruption
add the highest energies that we use to
really gentle micromixing as you can as
you mentioned we have now protocols to
help trypsin digestion with micro
streaming and regarding the throughput
you had actually today uh two very good
examples of how we can
achieve different objectives in the case
of here we work in low volumes 96 well
format
so you need mid energy with ignazi you
saw that it can work from 15 micro up to
one milliliter and then in the case of
one milliliter the throughput is 24
tubes
one by one or in the instruments that
your own has you can also work with one
ml tube with 24 tubes at a time
yeah um very well uh answered niko and
you know one of the things to keep in
mind you know once again not to beat on
it that it's not how much power you can
generate but what's optimal to get the
most out of your uh complex biological
matrix matrix so if you're working with
skin um cancerous tissues of course you
need more power and ignacio mentioned
also the cryo prep that can also enable
that process a lot
and speaking of ignacio the next
question is for him
so based on the histological activity
data that you shared
um
do you think or it would be possible to
identify uh some critical protein
markers
that can eventually down the road be
used for therapy for faster remission
is that a direction
yeah that's that's one of the points
that we uh we're working
so we have this panel of 70 proteins
that
they don't they have the potential to be
this kind of markers yes
excellent sir that's something that's
very positive
um next question is for our chairman
are fresh frozen tissue pieces um
example hot completely lysed by
sonication
or do small tissue pieces remain after
sonication so if tissue pieces remain in
the sample how does this affect
automated liquid handling um especially
on the bravo platform that you have used
yeah i know it's a good question um so
heart is a bit you know special tissue
because it's a bit of an exception
because it's quite sturdy
um
um other tissues um are are
more easily to lies and there we don't
need to worry so much about residual uh
tissue pieces
uh for specifically for heart you need
to
you know look into so what we did is
going
through two or three cycles
to optimize this
another thing is uh i would not make
i would not use two big tissue pieces so
if you go
over one milligram
um i think that's a bit you know too
ambitious and especially for tissues
like like heart
um
so there in such cases you might
consider doing a cryopulverization up
front and then use the
sonication to extract from that
which which works much better
yeah and
so uh just a
slight um addition to that question
geraldine so
do you really you know can it be
completely homogenized in your
experience based on you know the high
throughput platform you have worked or
do you do you have to work with you know
do you see that some species will still
be floating around
um
no no for
with the exception of heart um it's it's
for us the things we have seen it works
works quite well and we don't need to
worry about uh residual tissue pieces
okay excellent
um
the other question is also for you
geruan
was the reproducibility for the low cell
numbers satisfactory in terms of the
quantitative cv of proteins in case
um
you checked for that
yeah so so yeah it's a sort of good
question so we looked into that not
going extremely low uh maybe down to 100
to 1000 cells 200 cells i think and that
looked
really good at least you know as good as
we could achieve with
the manual procedure
as we had it before for for sp3
excellent thank you and uh so you know
we have just about a minute and a half
remaining
um on the hour uh so i i want to push
the last question um well the next
question is actually for
ignacy
do you foresee a metabolomic application
as well to support the
influencers especially on your eoe
project i mean experiments
um
i haven't thought about this
but
i can't foresee you can
do some
metabolism of the
breathing so there's already some
nice applications in which you can
directly
exfoliate into a mass spec
and this will give you the profile of
the metabolites that you are breathing
out this would be something better from
the tissues likely
yeah probably there's also something
that we can do from this
but uh to be honest we haven't um
thought to go into this direction
yeah
i mean it's easy to say multiomics uh
systems biology it's always difficult to
actually put together a whole story it
takes time
um so uh i think you know we have one
more question uh probably
uh
so uh nico this one for you probably the
last one how did you optimize the afa
how do you think we can optimize afa
conditions you know pip duty factor um
for experiments in general
sure so um i think that iron and ignazi
could say that it's a step-by-step
process
so we try different things we generally
provide studying settings and everything
can be and must be optimized because we
have as mentioned here different
settings that can be worked with so
we
we have again starting settings that
work and from there we can build in one
direction or the other and basically
what we do generally is what we call a
power course so we try at uh different
uh powers for a certain amount of time
uh
the treatment on the samples and from
there we can define what is to to modify
next
excellent so we are actually past the
regular time um so uh once again thank
you all uh for attending to those who uh
man those who manage to stay until the
end for engaging with us asking the
questions and
before i finish uh
thanks a lot my heartfelt gratitude to
gerald and ignacy for some
wonderful presentation sharing some
wonderful data
and nico
my uh my
co-conspirator in this whole thing but
you know you for for an excellent
presentation as well to get that got us
started and last but not the least uh
thanks a lot to everyone once again for
being with us thank you please feel free
to ask questions come by you know drop
in our at our website covaris.com and
drop a note um
asking any questions that you may have
thanks a lot
you